look at the baby oh my goodness she's
like I want to come on the
[Music]
ride okay here we
go I'm here at the Alaska Wildlife
Conservation Center with Sierra and Maya
to help Sarah out with a member of the
rain your her
hi you're perfect and no matter how
often we come here playing with the
reindeer never gets old la
la don't tell Mommy come here the
reindeer at awcc are very friendly um
often times I think they're my spirit
animals when they see the food truck
they come running they're certainly into
treats oh Chuckles look at him Chucky
fin are you getting
loving he's so sweet Ladies
Man Chuckles is the big guy in there
he's our old grandpa guy uh he's in
retirement now at this point oh my
goodness buddy you are closing your
eyeball I love Chuckles a lot and if you
have food or bring scratches he loves
you just as much back this is the
greatest day of my life could we do this
every day hey Chuck and then mom walks
up and he's like nope he's having none
of that what's this big scar thing here
I feel your lymph nose hold on let me
check I'm out it's like they went from
lovely scratches to I'm looking for
something to vet pets not in any exam
room I don't even know how to pet a dog
anymore without feeling for
everything okie dokie guys now that
we've had our Chuckles with Chuckles
it's time to turn our attention to
another member of the reindeer herd
Julius that's Julius oh man poor love
we're going to give Julius a look uh
Julius is a three-year-old steer he's
coming out of winter into the summer
right now and everybody's gotten some
good weight on them they've recovered
from the winter but Julius didn't come
out so well you can see his ribs and
stuff I don't know what's going on with
him as I'm looking at Julius across the
enclosure I I'm really concerned he
looks extremely thin like I can see all
of his vertebrae I can see the hip bones
and he wasn't looking like that a few
months ago if you look at everybody else
every and then there he is yeah right
we're not sure why he's dropping weight
so quickly because everyone in the Penn
is getting lots of good food they've had
a deworming regimen which we do every
spring now that we're kind of early
summer he should look chunky like
everybody else so we know something's
not right with them okay well um we
might try to put our P scope in and have
a look at his stomach I don't know that
we'll see anything but we'll see how
that goes just just because we've had
issues with these guys you know if
garbage gets dropped by visitors and it
blows in the pen these guys will eat it
so yeah like there's a Cookie Monster
these guys are the garbage monsters yeah
I know all right
Co I'm going to check our PTO scope
first and make sure it's ready to
roll come on SO for Julius I'm going to
sedate him because I need to put a scope
in and try and look at his esophagus and
kind of look down into his stomach all
right I'm suspicious about garbage being
in his stomach or the room in the reason
for that is that Ravens will fly over
the pens in this aial they'll get
garbage that's dropped by visitors or
anywhere in this area come on and they
tend to drop it in the large
enclosures
okay it popped out and I saw a little
bit of drug but he probably got enough
now for most of the animals they just
ignore it but for whatever reason
reindeer are garbage hounds keep feeling
it so when I have an animal that's doing
poorly I want to try and look to see if
I can actually see the garbage with the
scope he's down he's down how are are
you let me get a blindfold on
you okay this as you can see this little
beauty this is like just basically a
camera so like if I put it here I can
see my own ear there's a little screen
here if I put it up my own nose anyway
this is just a really nice way to look
down as esophagus and I'm going to try
and look in his room and I I may not see
everything that I need to see in there
but I'll at least get a look so this is
kind of a speculum that I go through so
he doesn't chew on my camera okay that's
freaking cool I know that's his tonsils
so do you see that watch when he
breathes so you see to the left right
here that's actually his tra yeah okay
try advancing a bit slowly as I'm
looking down julius's esophagus I just
see normal muscul normal esophageal
lining now I'm in his big gnarly rooming
ooh what is
that oh he's got a
big do you see that oh so that's right
just about into his room in it's got
like f stuck to it so that's like an
ulcer oh man that should not be there
basically an ulcer is it's like an
erosion in the stomach liting but how
that got there I don't know so now we're
in his room and just looking for what's
not supposed to be there any garbage or
any what was that that's just a little
bit of plant
material well we get in there a little
further and now you're going to see
nothing but green probably but I'll have
a
look this thing is so
cool I'm definitely not seeing plastic
but the thing is is that plastic can be
buried in um Rin contents you know okay
I'm going to reverse them when I have an
animal that's doing poorly and I see an
ulcer there's probably something bigger
going on
here basically the point of no return
now is to go in surgically open up his
room in and see if I find
garbage oh man poor love we're trying to
help you I'm going to come back tomorrow
and we're going to sedate him you know
even though the surgery is is going to
be hard on him without it I feel like
he's going to
[Music]
die today Michelle heads to the Reindeer
Farm in Palmer
Alaska where visitors commune with 120
domesticated
Caribou I have my favorites and they all
have names Denise Hardy cares for this
happy herd thank you but today hey one
of her top Bulls is feeling low we have
Dr Oakley here today to see Buster hi
Denise hi how's it going great so Buster
was our main breed bull last fall and I
was really excited to have lots of
babies from him and that's when we found
devastating news we think that he got in
a fight with another bull during the
breeding time and so it looks like
another bull kind of poked underneath
him with his antlers and ripped open his
testicle oh was actually outside of the
sack and swollen doubl the size of the
other testicle and there was infection
already present at that moment we had to
do an emergency castration to save his
life the surgery ended Buster's career
as a breeder bull last fall now with
Summer he's fallen ill again we've had
been finding infection off and on we
just don't know what's going on the
swelling is coming back again and um
he's limping pretty bad I think he's
been getting more and more in pain which
is why we're so glad you're here Buster
doesn't look well at all the area around
his scrotum and between his legs is
quite swollen and looks kind of fluidy
so all signs point to a chronic
infection so what I think we need to do
to kind of get at the root of the
problem is like fully mobilize them do a
bit of an exploration down there and try
and find where it's coming from okay all
right this poor guy of all places to
have an injury what a spot in the eight
months since Buster's castration
infection may have spread to other parts
of his body I'm going to try to move him
around and then out but before Michelle
can determine the extent of his illness
he must be herded into a squeeze shoot
for handling you cannot lean against
this because it will end badly for you
if you do there it
goes uhuh Buster reindeer can be
unpredictable especially when they're
not feeling good we have to stay in
control because he could kick someone or
trample someone and then it's game over
heads up coming at you bus the team must
close the pads around the 350 lb animal
the exact moment he runs in yeah this is
going to be good 3 2
one hold it back there you go there you
go
okay with Buster unable to kick or flee
I need a muscle Michelle safely
administers the set
okay you can let him go okay let's go
ahead and release all right hang on got
heads up heads up
ran he he he he we we're good the bull
should go down in a matter of
minutes once that adrenaline gets out of
their system they just go
[Music]
doy as Michelle and her team stabilize
Buster so we're just getting an IV set
up they discover one of his vitals is
already in the red temperature is 396
he's really heating up here so with a
temperature of
39.6 I mean that's
103° 104° F he's already getting at the
upper limit of what I want to see this
isn't good it's
39.7 he can't control his own body
temperature right now he starts to
overheat proteins start to break down
things start to fry and basically his
brain will start to cook Michelle needs
to stem is Fever by any means necessary
yeah so Pour Some Water right here on
him we're using the fluids to cool them
down as
well
39.2 was so much better with Buster
finally cooled off Michelle turns her
attention to his swollen
belly worried about what that is exactly
as soon as I touch his belly I'm worried
I can feel a lot of fluid and a lot of
swelling the worst case scenario is if
this is actually an abdominal infection
an infection inside his belly it's maybe
tracked all the way in up into his
organs and we could be talking about
complete organ failure I it's it kind of
feels like it's his whole
belly to help gauge how far the fluids
spread so I'm just going to see if I can
get some fluid out Michelle performs an
abdominal tap I'm going to put a needle
right into the abdomen and see if there
is any fluid coming out if I get fluid
back then I can have a better idea of if
there's an abdominal infection we can
actually culture it and see what type of
bacteria it is and make sure we get the
right antibiotic to treat it I'm not
getting anything out but as I'm putting
it in and I get it right into the
abdomen no fluid comes out the question
is where is all that fluid around there
to find out Michelle must cut Buster
open perfect so what I'm going to do is
I'm going to try and explore it a bit to
see um what is up in
there uh-oh
this tissue is brutal sick as I'm
getting into the area I'm finding this
kind of big thickened area of cellulitis
in the skin it's just not very healthy
tissue that tissue is a clue that a
powerful infection may be lingering
deeper inside that keeps going kind of
in
there ooh that doesn't look
good
uh-oh this tissue is brutal
thick Michelle is trying to find the the
root cause behind Buster's escalating
pain and swollen
belly ooh look at that as she opens a
channel inside she hits Pay Dirt this
goes in super deep right off the bat a
deep pocket filled with pus a clear sign
of
infection this is a fairly good siiz
cavity it has two different tracks going
off in two different directions it's
really starting to flow now there's a
lot of pus straining out we want to get
as much of that out as we Poss possibly
can we're getting some goo and I'm just
kind of continuing to put the flush in
there and allowing it to drain I flushed
a ton like probably you know two cups
worth of past out of there I'm just what
I'm trying to do is get far enough up
that I can open it up so I can put a
drain in there now I'm going to go in
with tubing that I'll actually suture
inside so it stays there but it'll
follow the track of the abscess and hang
out of the body now we're getting
somewhere and that's what's going to
keep allowing things that are are high
up inside Under the Skin to follow the
path of that tube right to the outside
of the body and drain we'll remove it in
either a few days or in a week okay a
shot of heavyduty antibiotics will cover
Buster for good measure but that's no
guarantee he'll kick this infection I'm
not sure what the prognosis is for
Buster the problem is it's a chronic
infection and that's really really tough
to treat and get rid of it's just hard
to say if he'll be able to fight it off
I felt like he just moved
just tell me if you feel him pulling
against you okay he is getting um a
little light okay we're just finishing
up he's starting to move his tongue a
little bit kind of Twitches nostril so I
know he's getting ready to wake up
gently roll him up now as gently as
possible I just don't want him to take
off on us all right I'm going to give
him the
reversal okay I think we can let him up
so okay clear yep just let him up back
away please easy
buster
pretty good up yeah so for the next few
days Denise is just going to keep a
close eye on Buster it's going to be
just making sure that he's eating and
comfortable until I come back to check
him well at least we got some of the
puss out of there so Buster is a huge
part of our herd and our family even as
a castrated mail hopefully we can cure
him of this for final this
time now that ERS out of commission as a
breeder Denise has chosen another bull
to become the next daddy in the herd hi
Walt he a sweet
boy the next case I have for Michelle is
Walt he's a nice young male that's
halter trained I intend for him to be
the breed bull this fall because of his
fantastic
personality but Walt recently suffered a
mysterious injury that has Denise
worried he may not feel well enough for
breeding he has a blue blue eye ooh okay
Walt's Eye turned from brown to Blue
within a few days I'm not sure what's
going on with that I think it feel it
feels like he's blind like when we kind
of go at it so it's concerning it's
scary because we don't know what caused
it I actually have seen eyes swell up
out of the eye socket and have to be
removed so that's a huge concern we'll
get set
up when you suddenly have um an animal
that develops kind of a bluish looking
eye that usually means there's been some
injury to the Cornet to the surface of
the eye hey buddy the old blue eye it's
okay I need to find out what the injury
is and how bad it is it could be caused
by a foreign body um it could be an
infection that's transmitted by flies or
it could even be like an internal
infection that's pushing the eye out
here comes Walt breeding season begins
in less than 2 months if Walt's not
feeling better soon it could threaten
his chances to become Denise's next stud
bll a oh that ice sore is it huh oh love
let's have a look at that laying down is
that okay with you he's going down right
when I go to examine Walt he just lays
right down he's just not feeling well
and you can tell he's really
uncomfortable I know it's tender isn't
it it's a little tricky to kind of get
in there not get a antler in the
forehead oopsie the good news is that
he's definitely able to see me I can see
that he's reacting to my movements and
he still has some Vision in that eye
oops oops oops hold on Buddy hold on
W the Bucking Bull's in agony so I'm
going to put some drops in it so the iee
won't be tender this basically freezes
it let see if I can have a look at this
I know you don't want it to open the eye
to the Sun the bright light is not only
causing pain for Walt it's also causing
problems for Michelle let's bring the
tarp and we're going to have to huddle
underneath he's in the squeeze out in
the open sun's out it's really tough to
actually do a proper exam of an eye like
that so we're actually going to cover
him up just get a little bit of shade
perfect he you're
okay I'm really sorry
Walt now that I'm under the tarp I'm
just trying to get a view from all
angles and light up the parts of the eye
that I need to
see so you can see all those red vessels
you need to look up at us don't look
down and it's pretty tough to see
through all
that that kind of blue it's just that
the corneal surface is no longer clear
like it should be that blue film is
basically an infiltration of cells
trying to fight infection and there's a
lot of swelling there's a lot of fluid
and because of all that it's really
tough to get all the way in there to see
right in there but Michelle is able to
catch tiny glimpses into the deeper part
of the eye I don't see any sign of a
foreign body but it looks like there
there was a poke something poked in the
eye either scratch or poke when I look
at the center of the eye I see a very
clear kind of Slash in the surface of
the cornea so he had some type of injury
to his eye it's like probably some type
of puncture piece of wire something like
that it really just looks like it's on
the surface a surface injury is good
news but it still needs rigorous
treatment to combat infection from
setting in now if this was a dog at home
and you know we could give them drops
three times a day great but that's not
going to be the case with the reindeer
what we're going to do is I'm going to
put some antibiotics actually in the
conjunctiva like the underside of his
eyelid and it'll slowly leak out onto
his eye and that's one way to avoid kind
of giving eye drops every day
administering antibiotics to a
reindeer's eyelid is not for the faint
of heart there was a small needle like a
red one I basically have to put a needle
into the tissues around his eye hi back
now he's going to have to stay still I
want to stick a needle actually in his
eye and I need to put it here in this
eyelid what I just need to do is you
know keep that needle point at a safe
angle I don't want to poke him in the
eye so I have to be careful and just
keep everything kind of smooth and
controlled in case he were to
jump no don't
move I don't like sharp objects com to
my eye can you imagine a reindeer seeing
that coming and not understanding what's
happening so and we're going to BLB it
in there the eye could deflate if it
gets popped by a needle on accident I
trust her that she's going to be able to
do this without stabbing him in the
eyeball kind of jams up cuz it's really
thick stuff okay we'll get the rest of
it
buddy it's really hurt didn't Jack a
small
needle wal the raineer has a gash on his
eyeball so to treat it Michelle must
inject an antibiotic straight into his
eyelid this treatment is pretty rough I
don't envy my little Walt to have to go
through
this go the injection must be
administered painstakingly
slow kind of jams up cuz it's really
thick stuff okay we'll get the rest of
it buddy penicillin is just a really
thick viscous liquid and I'm trying to
inject it through a small needle so it
doesn't
hurt
wo watch
yourself but because it's so thick it's
taking a long time to get out see if I
can get any more in
there what a good
reindeer that's a pretty good BL I think
we're good the full dose is finally in
all right buddy there we go one last
injection should keep Walt's discomfort
at Bay that was for pain and swelling I
you won like that I'm sorry woo or so in
a couple days I'm hoping to see a lot
less of those red angry vessels around
his eye and definitely a resolution of
some of the blue
eyes I'll be back in a few days and
we'll recheck and see if we've got any
progress okay when Michelle returns
Denise will find out if Walt stands a
chance at recovery so he can father the
next generation of reindeer babies we
really got to get Walt back out there
feeling good and doing his
job
[Music]
this morning operation reindeer
continues at the Alaska Wildlife
Conservation Center you guys can just
stay back unless we need to come in okay
okay Michelle is concerned Julius the
reindeer you see that may have ingested
garbage oh man I should not be
there I'm pretty concerned about Julius
but unfortunately we've had reindeer
that have passed and we found garbage in
their stomach I've get it all righty did
it inject yeah good with what he's
showing me based on his body condition
considering the rest of his cohorts are
in really good shape I hope doct Oakley
find something in there just to explain
what's going on oh he's going down in
the corner there oh he's
down Julius looks nice and sedate so
we're going to come in with our little
reindeer mover put him in that bag and
then get him into clck one two three
keep his head tipped
down ready
yep soon as we get him in the clinic I'm
going to be putting in an IV catheter
running some
fluids he's small but he's big enough
that we can't really put him on our
surgery table so we're actually going to
have him on the floor in the infirmary
okay good we're going to have to
basically shave his whole flank clean
that off really well and you know get
busy with
surgery I'm just doing a block that he
doesn't feel where I'm going to cut so
just did a little bit of a block there
and then I'm going to end up doing my
cut right about
there okay let's scrub them
up as I'm getting ready to do the
surgery I'm definitely feeling like
tension in the air cuz I'm a little bit
nervous about how high risk he is with
the anesthesia he's like borderline
emaciated okie dokie but we are
definitely point where we have no other
choice all right now it's time to see if
we can go in and pull off a miracle
[Music]
cutting hoping I find an explanation in
here for why he's so skinny and why he's
not getting better so it would be great
news if you saw a big chunk of garbage
oh yeah that would be
awesome
okay so this is his room in we're going
to pull this
out see it's kind of get gassy his room
in now that I've kind of got it part of
it out I mean this is the organ this big
large four chambered stomach that gets
bloated and you can see how large it is
I'm I'm just holding one small part of
it it's a balloon that's going to be
like a fart and as soon as I make the
first cut it's
like I kind of just directed it over at
Maya oh my God
it's m something's kind of sour there
dang oo smells like death kind of it
does not smell
healthy all of the roomin contents are
just sort of coming out under pressure
it's a real frothy kind of bloaty
material that isn't quite right so now
Maya I need you to hang on to this but
let me get some of this out of the way
it's a volcano frothy frothy
glute I've never seen it like so frothy
it should be more like matte it's like
baking soda and vinegar oh yes it's like
we just dropped a Mentos in a Diet Coke
bottle hang on a second we need the
edges like out down a bit yeah oh there
we go wa oh yeah this I don't know but
it's not
normal whoa this is like serious froth
mhm as I'm looking in julius's room in I
was not expecting like stuff to come
pouring out that is definitely not
normal so something is going on here can
we prop him some more please so that
gravity is our friend here we just want
to make sure that that's kind of going
down and not into his
belly there we go there's so much you
guys wow oh there we go whoa what is
that I don't know but that wasn't that
seemed weird
more oh yeah this is what is that I
don't know but it's not
normal as all this like kind of Oozy
frothy green material is coming out I
feel something like harder and longer as
I pull it's like doesn't want to give
and I'm like okay garbage bag it's
garbage so so this is a I think a
garbage but it's not normal anyway
whatever it is it's rocks and stuff
that's all wound up there that's garbage
bag right there plastic see that maybe
we could have a separate tub for this
this size of a piece of garbage
definitely would cause weight loss and
it definitely would interfere with the
fermentation going on in his room and it
would just be a total blockage and not
give him any nutrition at all this looks
like the gorest I mean it's brutal I
know okay let's do the big glove so I
can really get in there what I'm doing
now is basically just trying to get in
there and get all the goo out so I can
find possibly any more garbage in
there okay I'm like deep in the room
then and I'm up against his belly
oh there's like rocks in
here holy what are those rocks I don't
know how he'd even eat that or they
could maybe form like hard chunks you
know around some of the
garbage okay so there's no other big
chunks in there so we're going to start
closing this up let's rinse this
first yeah right there get up that going
the right
way okie dokie bud I got to cool off a
second totally so look at
that how that all fit in the
stomach I'm very happy to get that
plastic and that garbage out of the way
it's kind of like the Smoking Gun all
right my I'm going to suture that closed
right there I'm feeling like okay I hope
this was it I hope this is all we need
to do because I can't find anything else
so at least we've given him another shot
how'd he do he did fabulous we're not
done yet I'm just closing the last bit
of the skin now you would not believe
the stuff we pulled out of him oh I'm
really glad we did it cuz there was
definitely a couple things that were not
going to be letting things through yeah
okay buddy oh my God I can't stand
up oh I can't hardly stand up woo clean
up an i
one
this morning Michelle Ventures out
across the Alaskan Frontier to the
Reindeer Farm in Palmer okay
everybody come on guys today she has
over four dozen patients to Wrangle in
an annual reindeer ride push it
[Music]
up today is her processing day so we're
giving full physicals to all the
reindeer come on we've got big bulls
lots of females lots of babies and it's
really hot out the animals are stressed
so we're going to try and quickly run
them all through they're all complaining
a little bit so we've got our work cut
out for us today slowly slowly slow slow
slow slow the handlers funnel the herd
through the gauntlet of gates and shoots
to queue up close it close it close it
close it close
it okay we ready for the first one then
send it's go time here it comes
all right this is Michelle's one chance
each year to find and treat any ailments
that might otherwise go unseen she's got
lumps everywhere this looks more like
infection so we might hit her with some
antibiotic oh no no no no no Stay Stay
Stay Stay we need to you know check
everybody's teeth have a look at their
eyes eyes look great that one looks
good s some might have foot issues can
we get you to stand up oh good girl
there you go needs a vaccine D
worm
sand we're going to tag all the babies
all tagged
up
okay oh oh scalpel please we'll probably
have to express a few abscesses pimple
popping 101 and treat any injuries we
find the antler is broken in here we're
going to have to remove
it okay who's coming
next better grab her cuz she's going to
flail here in a second Maya can put set
of gloves on please so much hair you're
a beautiful
baby today is the first time for the
babies to run through the shoes no no no
no no so they're a little confused they
don't know where to
go
baby so as much as possible we're going
to just carry them from the shoot out to
the fence Bo boing boing back to Mommy
you go and the adults are Old Pros
they'll do anything to avoid getting
caught oh let her through Let Her Go
they'll try and jump the shoot or just
rip right through
it it's dangerous work the flailing
reindeer can take out a farm hand from a
kick to the gut or an antler in the
eye all
right Let Her Go Let Her
Go hey that one looks
good
okay oh no get get him get him get are
you okay yeah Bulldog him today is H
processing day and Michelle is 49
reindeer deep in medical Mayhem 463
can't let her go now there's just one
patient left before the threat of broken
bones is over for another year last
one fiery
vacine de warmer okay see compl
completed yep wo all right we are done
it's all done it was a hot day and a
long day but we got through everybody
and we made it high fives all
around nice man you earned
[Music]
[Applause]
your we're ready we're ready the Oakley
are ready for their ride you guys are
all on the back too like I'm a
legitimate chauffeur you we just kind of
tour us around and we could wait at
everybody oh God
oops wait we actually want Sarah to
[Applause]
[Music]
drive so we're coming out of winter here
at awcc and we're going to go see Caesar
today he's a reindeer male who's having
some issues with his
antlers okay and which one has it shed
that one that big one Caesar the big guy
out there on the left yep he's got a big
and a small antler by the looks of it
typically male reindeer shed their
antlers as soon as rut's over we've
castrated all of our reindeer it causes
some imbalances with the hormones and
the old antlers just don't
shed Caesar's issue right now is that he
can't let go of his old antlers
unfortunately his new antlers started
hanging on to the old antlers and so
that's a problem because it can start to
cause little cuts and injuries and then
that gets infected there can be a lot of
puss it can start to grow really weird
so we want to get the old antlers out of
the way who's this one with the attitude
that's f a fern oh my God Fern she's so
cute and she's been a little bottle baby
that we pulled out last year just about
died on us oh reindeer kisses is he
going to not come over here yeah he's
the only one not coming over here
unfortunately Caesar's not the
friendliest of the reindeer he's not
really on Santa's team so he doesn't
come hang out with us that easily Dr
ople's going to have to sedate
him I think he's coming over
now are you ready to go I'm ready let's
go
okay oh look at that he knew
instantly hi
[Music]
Fern chase him further you stinker one
of the females went after him they're
chasing him away which is annoying
in the reindeer herd we have a couple of
ladies that are kind of bullies um you
know I feel like every herd kind of has
their own batch of Mean Girls and the
reindeer herd certainly has theirs don't
chase him
seriously all
right well it hit him nicely it
injected the girls in general are just
not nice
oh oh there he goes he's down if they
start getting rough with him do you want
me and Britney to run in there oh she's
getting no she's getting rough with him
Sarah she's going to poke his eye if she
keeps doing that oh yep yep yep I of
think he might pop up so let's just be
real careful go around behind him no
don't you bug
him oh that was perfect
see what we're looking at here ooh is it
really gross what is
that Caesar's a mess that new antler is
like black and bubbly it's like
something coming out of the swamp it's
causing like abesses and stuff you see
there's an abscess there do you see that
oh look at it P it's got p on it it's
got a bunch of weird bubbles it's not
good and it actually could be dangerous
for him if it can cause infections that
can go deeper and because this antler
tissue is infected and inflamed right
now it hurts and he doesn't want to bump
into anybody and the females in the pen
know that they're already picking on
them they're pushing them away from food
they're giving him a little bit of a
hard time because they know he's not
wanting to use those antlers
anymore yeah hoping we could kind of
loosen it but I don't know what really
bums me out is there's no kind of
wobbling almost like a loose tooth that
I think I can get it it's not budging it
is still in
there and it's hanging on so tight so
we'll probably just have to cut it can I
get some giggly
wire giggly wire is basically just a saw
that's wire you can see it's got a bunch
of little sharp knives that make up the
wire you're doing
great great job you're so good at this
Dr you're still getting the turn nice
try that dead antler is basically just
condensed bone but there's no feeling to
it so it doesn't hurt but if you were to
do it too fast it can create a lot of
heat that's a lot of friction as you're
going that heat could travel down and
damage any of the live tissues oh this
is great for the
ABS
yep it's a pretty intense job it's kind
of like being at the dentist office when
they're grinding on your teeth it smells
like that and it's kind of a pain in the
butt cuz you're all hunched over yeah
girl yes it really does wonders for your
back I
promise don't start a
fire maybe slow down actually
seriously Sarah's got the elbow grease
going she's like flying I didn't want to
overheat like don't set a fire Sarah
come
on you almost got it through
dude that's not smoke that's powder but
it does get really hot as you know
oh so there's a little bleeder there but
it's already kind of stopping on its own
that little bit of bleeding looks
shocking but it's not as bad as it looks
it's just that I have to cut through a
little bit of that fresh velvet and that
stuff bleeds like stink I mean there's
no getting around it there's going to be
a bit of Gore there's going to be a lot
of bleeding with this I might try to
take this front chunk off too all right
so now Maya let's get you over here with
that white jacket I don't want to be any
anywhere near the front of the animal
for once the blood is like squirting out
there's P rining because I've got a
fairly new white coat Maya is definitely
willing to get down and dirty but she
also will choose fashion over
practicality when she's choosing her
work
clothes yes okay thank you good
job this is the fruits of our
efforts
there you go Bud oh cough and a big
stretch good boy look at the fat butt
cheeks on him he like where' my where'
my helmet go why do he look
lopsided a a love you're going to grow
them they're growing right now it's here
comes the girls they're like let's check
this out they're going to make so much
fun of him to him he'll be back on good
terms with his girls soon enough when
any of the males lose their antlers even
naturally the the girls will chase him
around a bit and Bully him cuz he's been
chasing them around for a while and now
it's their
turn let's go can't wait to drive the
Oakley it's my number one
job let's go
chaur
[Applause]
faster
[Music]
it's follow-up day at the Reindeer Farm
in Palmer okay Michelle's here to see if
there's good news for Denise or if more
serious intervention is in order for
Buster and Walt let's look at Buster
next Buster has been struggling to beat
a life-threatening infection for
months I've been watching Buster and he
looks great looking pretty feisty Buster
Buster's spunky attitude may be a sign
he's feeling
but Michelle won't know for sure until
she can inspect his belly up close okay
go ahead and send him here he comes the
only way to safely perform an exam on
the revved up bull is to trap him in the
squeeze well
Buster so you can see the drain where it
went in I'm to cut the suture there and
then pull it right
through and that one no stop stop stop
don't kick
me now that the drains are out of the
way Michelle can give Buster a
definitive prognosis that feels a lot
better Denise yeah still a little bit of
swelling but that hard stuff that hard
swelling is gone is
[Music]
greato okay it's hard to believe this is
the same guy I mean the swelling's
almost gone there's hardly any drainage
he's doing awesome he's good let him go
release awesome he's running good he
looks fantastic he definitely is not
going to be breeding the SP
but the herd is where the home is and so
he's right with his
home they did their job
you across the pen good boy Walt awaits
his doctor's
orders the one-year-old bull was
handpicked by Denise to become the next
breeder in the herd until a mysterious
infection put his future in Jeopardy he
had a kind of a bluish film over his eye
from an injury to the cornea what I hope
to see when I look at Walt's Eye today
is that kind of blue film is resolving
and there's no additional swelling or
redness around the eye okay well watch I
don't lose my eye looking at yours let
me have a look here in the shade let's
see Sierra come here I need you to open
the eyelid for me while I'm doing this
you're going to probably need two hands
there you go there we
go keep holding that
there the opacity is decreased about 50%
oh that looks so much better that is
healing up nicely it looks much better
it's resolving quite a bit interior
chamber is clear even the redness like
the really angry vessels that were kind
of coming in on the top of his cornea
those have gone away quite a bit let's
put a genom in I don't think we need any
more penicillin a dab of antibiotic
ointment will help kill any residual
bacteria in the reindeer's eye it looks
so much better yeah Walt's baby blue
should be back to Brown in another
week's time yay all right Walt I'm so
happy to have him doing well three 2 1
go see you later Walt I saw a difference
within 24 hours of Dr Oakley treating
that eye can you believe the difference
to that oh yeah yeah I can eyes heal
really quickly with a little bit of help
so yeah they kind of have to we're
really excited to be able to have a be
the breed bull this fall and the the
daddy to the babies in the herd woohoo
but before Michelle says goodbye there's
one last subject to run the reindeer
Gauntlet I want to see if they can catch
me with that okay go for it midair go
for the Superman ready pat Superman
catchy to catch the you'll never catch
me I'm just telling
you to really know how to out with these
guys I should experience the shoot
myself I got her I got her oh all right
fine
I'm caught ear tag me I guess I'll stick
to my day
[Music]
job